foreign secretary is with us this
morning ladies and gentlemen good
morning wherever you're watching us um
are you a Taylor Swift fan I do like a
bit of Taylor Swift you looked as though
you would yeah I do like a bit of Taylor
Swift at the karaoke I think it suits my
Persona okay what's your favorite song
uh we are never ever getting back I knew
you would say that as well I suppose you
could sing that to Liz trust couldn't
you uh no tell me about this deal
well look
um we have got to get a grip of the
international trade in uh in in human
misery these people traffickers who are
putting lives at risk by facilitating
the illegal Crossing of migrants into
the UK and around the world we've got to
get a grip of that and we've got to do
that with Partners that's why I was part
of the reason why I was in France last
week speaking with my opposite number
and the reason that the Home Secretary
is speaking with her opposite number in
France because we do need to work with
our International Partners including
France and including the countries from
which these people come
to break the business model of these
people traffickers and to prevent these
illegal Crossings into the UK
from previous deals
well we need to always adapt and update
we we see that these people traffickers
constantly changing their tactics the
way they use technology how they try and
evade law enforcement so it's important
that we that we speak with our
International friends and allies about
updating our uh our procedures but also
of course we need to make sure that
these these these deals these
Arrangements these agreements continue
and that's what the that's what the home
sex will be doing so is there any major
difference between this deal and the
ones that pretty Patel did and the the
one that would that cost us tens of
millions that have been done previously
as well and also the 2K agreement so
those deals have been uh effective
they've not completely stopped The
Crossings but for example uh France has
stopped 29
000 29 000 illegal Crossings that's
twice the number that they stopped in
the previous year these are significant
numbers sadly unfortunately there are
still significant numbers of people
crossing the channel so we've got to
work on that we've also got to work on
repatriating them back to their
countries quickly but these agreements
do have an effect they are not the
complete solution we have to as I say
work with the countries from which these
people come the countries that they're
traveling through and also of course we
need to make sure that our legal
processes are fast effective fair but
also are understood that that we will
repatriate people we will send people
back if they don't have a legitimate
reason to be here so the 80 million quid
that we're going to give to France are
this latest deal uh what sort of numbers
would you like to see reduced by the
French side in order for it to have been
worth the money well look these are the
things that the Home Secretary will be
discussing with her opposite numbers
look we want of course
as I say I was speaking with the French
uh foreign
so it wasn't it's it's not part of my uh
part of the process to come up with the
specific numbers that's for the Home
Secretary and her counterpart but the
French of course understand how
important this is they don't want to see
these people on their Beaches they don't
want to see these criminal gangs
operating in their country and we've
made with the cooperation of
international Partners we've made over
500 arrests of these people traffickers
we've broken over 50 criminal gangs this
is what we do by working yes exactly
it's what we do by work so there's still
more work and you also trumped the 29
000 so what I'm saying to you is for the
80 million quid that it's going to cost
us what do you want to see as a result
well the numbers the numbers are well
ultimately what we want to see is these
uh uh these these Crossings reduced
completely but we have to be we have to
be realistic that the the people
traffickers are working incredibly hard
to try and so we don't have any law
enforcement okay we need to work just as
hard to counter their illegal activities
we wanted the Brits wanted to be part of
the patrols to try to stop the crossings
that was one of the sticking points and
the French wouldn't let us how do you
feel about that well we have got to make
sure that we understand the respective
jurisdictions we need to make sure that
our law enforcement officials are
working as effectively as possible the
details of the agreement that we
thrashed out between their home sector
and the French interior Minister
the important thing is that we work
closely the important thing is that
we're sharing information the important
thing is we are gripping the people
traffickers and preventing their uh evil
business that is exactly how we do that
that will be done that will be agreed
through negotiations but the important
thing is that we are and we will
continue to work very very closely and
the other thing is I mean the last two
deals I'm just looking at the numbers
pretty Patel 54 million pounds before
that November 2020 28 million pound deal
they haven't been successful because
we're seeing them coming over migrants
coming over whether you call them a
league or not in in in record numbers so
well look they've not been they've not
spit no one thing provides the complete
answer to this and that's why that's why
as I say we've got to deal with the the
situation the countries where these
people come from whether it's whether
they're fleeing economic circumstances
or War or conflict we need to try and
make the countries that they're coming
from better so there's less incentive
for them to leave we have to make sure
we work with our International partners
and as I say the the deals that uh
swella's predecessor put in place have
had an effect they have not completely
stopped it and that sadly is why we're
still seeing uh people uh Crossing on
small boats but they have had an effect
they have broken a number of these
criminal gangs they have prevented uh
tens of thousands of people crossing the
channel and they have broken a signif a
significant number
record numbers but indeed and we are not
going to rest we are not going to rest
until we get a resolution on this and
and the the arrangement that we're
making with friends is incredibly
important
um and it's part of an overall mix
um we want our border force to be on uh
French territory which is what we've
agreed but apparently the Border Force
are going on strike so what does that
lead to do
well I think it is uh look we we all
recognize that public servants are under
uh pressure because of the economic
situation we're seeing right across the
globe and we we absolutely recognize
that but ultimately there is a really
important job to do the uh the Border
Force officials play an important part
of keeping our country safe
um I would uh I would want them to be
focused exclusively on that and they
have to recognize that this is a a very
difficult
economic situation right across the
globe I understand but what does it
leave the deal if they're on strike well
as I say we will uh we will I have no
doubt work with the representative
bodies of the Border force uh to uh to
encourage them to stay focused on the
job at hand but ultimately uh
at a minister level we will be
negotiating with our friends and allies
around the world to put Arrangements in
place to protect the wrong strike to
protect ourselves from these legal
migrations okay um data released to the
refugee Council by their home office 122
206 migrants waiting to have their
claims assessed 725 have been waiting
for more than five years isn't that
where we should be investing the money
well look we do have to speed up the uh
the the the processing of uh claims and
there are there are improvements that
we've driven through the uh through the
recent legislation we took through the
house legislation that was opposed by
the labor party to prevent things like
multiple claims which massively
massively slow down the system to ensure
that the processing of migrants can be
done fairly but fast that's better for
everybody it's better for them so they
know what their status is it's better
for the UK because it cost us less money
and we can resolve these issues and so
the uh so the legislation that we have
recently put in place will go a long way
to addressing those long delays which
are not good for anyone they're not good
for the migrants themselves they're
certainly not good for the UK I was
looking for um ways to try to save money
or invest money in order to make things
better for migrants ETC and we've been
hearing from the immigration Minister
and he has said weirdly he said Robert
generic that those coming should be
given simple functional accommodation
that does not create an additional pull
factor for one second do you think that
people are fleeing the situation in
Afghanistan so they can stay in a
Premier Inn in Dover well we do know so
the Afghans that supported us whilst we
were in Afghanistan we we do have a duty
to them and we are absolutely supporting
them and that's why we have supported a
significant number coming to the UK
however but this directly to your
question however there are definitely
people coming to the UK not because they
are fleeing persecution because they are
seeking economically a better life now I
completely get that the UK is a great
place to live and work and it is
unsurprising that people around the
world want to come here but we we know
there's video footage there are people
they are there are people posting onto
social media the fact that they are
really happy that they are coming to the
UK that they've got to the UK seeking a
better economic life not feeling
persecution seeking a better economics
that is that is that is very very
different to the people fleeing uh
some people are definitely motivated to
come to the UK because they feel this is
a nicer and better place to live and
work than where they currently live they
are economic migrants and it's really
really important when we have this uh
discussion about illicit immigration
there are some people like the Hong Kong
like the Hong kongers like the
ukrainians like the Afghans who are
fleeing war or persecution there are
others who are economic migrants we we
really need to recognize and some of
those economic migrants put themselves
in the hands of people traffickers but
we have to recognize there is a
difference how many do you think will
finally send to Rwanda
well I I I don't know I I don't know
what we do no no we are uh we're going
through legal processes to uh to get
those flights
but we will continue to put forward
plans to break the economic model of the
people traffickers the message we need
to send to the people who put their
lives and money in the hands of people
traffickers is it is a waste it's a
waste and it's still coming but we have
to make 120 million we have to make sure
that people recognize that it is a waste
of money
to to pay people traffickers to get to
the UK because they will be repatriated
and finally we're almost out of time the
boss has been um criticizing Putin in
one of the papers this morning for not
going along to the G20 Summit if he
changed his mind and he did go
would our prime minister sit down with
him well we will confront Russia about
their behavior we're not going to I
don't know so we're what we're not going
to do is we're not going to normalize
the relationship we're not going to
normalize relationship with Russia
because Russia has invaded its neighbor
it has breached the uh un chart you
can't criticize him for not going and
then not sit down we will absolutely as
we do when I was at the United Nations
uh a little earlier on this Autumn I sat
in the same room as Sergey lavrov uh I
criticized the Russian invasion of
Ukraine I stood in solidarity
International colleagues and Friends
if at whatever level Russia is
represented at the G20 the Prime
Minister will absolutely call them out
absolutely confronted with their Elite
for their illegal unprovoked invasion of
Ukraine
okay I'm not going and then you're
you're trying to make a I mean you're
trying to make a I don't know a question
out of something which for me is a
really really straightforward we will
confront them we are not going to
normalize them we are not going to act
with them as we would do with our our
friends and allies at the G20 that is we
are not going to normalize the
relationship in light of the appalling
uh uh activity
that we've seen Russia conducting we
will absolutely confront them we will
absolutely call them out good to see you
as always thank you very much indeed
thank you